[Musica]
mi presento io sono dario sono uno dei
fondatori di officina creativa una
realtà imprenditoriale calabrese una
realtà imprenditoriale che è nata e
cresciuta in quel sud proprio quello con
i tassi di disoccupazione altissimi
[Musica]
lui
a differenza di molti coetanei sono nato
e vissuto tutto il senso della mia vita
nella mia città natale crotone
per fortuna però ho avuto la la mia
famiglia che ha investito molti soldi
affinché potessimo viaggiare
ho avuto la possibilità di visitare
tutta europa
all'età di 17 anni
ho visto 17 tra le capitali tra le
maggiori capitali europee le più grandi
città europee oltre 20 città in tutta
italia
ho visitato il louvre di parigi
il museo del prado a madrid
il btc museum di londra
e il van gogh museum di amsterdam
se però che i miei genitori
mi dicevano dario domani andiamo al
museo la mia faccia
era più o meno come quella di questo
bambino
vivendo
il crotone
avendo vissuto tutta la mia vita crotone
ma avendo avuto la fortuna di viaggiare
iniziai a chiedermi perché perché la mia
città non poteva vivere di turismo
perché la mia città con una storia così
lontana non potesse valorizzare in
termini economici
quello che era la sua storia e fu così
che nel 2016 insieme ai miei compagni di
viaggio decidemmo di trasferire quelle
che erano le nostre passioni le nostre
follie in termini di innovazione le
nostre passioni sulla tecnologia sulle
nuove tecnologie e di applicarlo al bene
al settore dei beni culturali con la
visione di trasformare il nostro
territorio in qualcosa di estremamente
più attrattivo e quindi che possa creare
un'economia
questo progetto venne selezionato nel
2016 alla prima edizione dell'italian
innovation day a tokyo
li raccontano la nostra idea di start up
innovative
questo
acque dall'esigenza di trasformare
quello che una visita una classica
visita al museo in qualcosa di diverso
trasformare quello che era la semplice
visita al museo in un concetto nuovo un
concetto di esperienza sapete il
concetto di esperienza nel mondo è
qualcosa che ha un
una una ridondanza particolare un caso
studio per fargli capire quello che vi
sto dicendo è il colosso del delle
guesthouse airbnb
ha speso circa 5 milioni di euro
per acquisire trip fori al inserire
all'interno del suo parco servizi
proprio l'esperienza
trasformare
l'arte la cultura o un semplice museo in
qualcosa di diverso in qualcosa che crei
emozioni in qualcosa che possa
raggiungere il cuore delle persone
noi siamo convinti che possa dare un
nuovo rilancio economico
con il nostro team con il team di
officina creativa
abbiamo lavorato a un progetto di start
up di tre giovanissime calabresi
virtual agorà virtù l'agorà non è altro
che un viaggio totalmente immersivo dove
viene raccontata la storia dell'antica
kroton qua abbiamo un fotogramma di
quello che si vede all'interno della
dell'occhiale un'esperienza
completamente immersiva dove a 360 gradi
con l'audio sparato nelle orecchie si
riesce ad essere catapultati
in quell'epoca si riesce a rivivere
quello che era l'antica kroton tutto
questo tramite dei visori degli occhiali
vr
e tutto questo completamente svincolato
da luoghi fisici perché questi occhiali
vr possono essere trasportati
potenzialmente in tutto il mondo e
possono essere potenzialmente replicati
in tutto il mondo
abbiamo fatto vivere questa esperienza a
diverse persone
al termine dell'esperienza abbiamo fatto
delle domande abbiamo chiesto del
feedback in tal merito
la risposta è stata quasi unanime
wow
e allora se prendiamo il caso di virtual
agorà o prendiamo il caso studio
dell'ara pacis a roma ci possiamo
rendere conto che realmente questo tipo
di tecnologie possono cambiare il metodo
di fruizione dell'arte un altro esempio
è la
caccia al tesoro nella reggia di caserta
un gioco un viaggio realizzato tramite
realtà aumentata
dove
l'arte si miscela al gioco
la nostra idea è quella di trasformare
il vecchio sistema di visita di un museo
o di fruizione dell'arte che potrebbe
essere rappresentato dall audioguida dai
lettori qr code da tutte questo tipo di
tecnologia in qualcosa di estremamente
innovativo in qualcosa che riesca
appunto a raggiungere il cuore delle
persone
realtà aumentata realtà virtuale tramite
la realtà virtuale riusciamo a
catapultare l'utente dovunque possa
stimolare le proprie emozioni
beh ve lo ricordate questo bambino
beh ora i bambini ci penso io tu hai già
parlato troppo
potrei essere io stessa a raccontare la
mia storia in prima persona
scusate mi presento io sono hera lacinia
moglie di zeus regina degli dei
venivo venerata come dea protettrice
delle donne della fertilità femminile
della famiglia e del matrimonio
sono una statua parlante e sono in grado
di raccontarvi la vera storia
dell'antica kroton
e sono in realtà uno stato normale come
tutte le altre
vedete
il fatto che io esista è il risultato
della ricerca e sviluppo del team di
officina creativa che mi ha dato la
possibilità di partecipare a questo the
duck talk insieme a voi vi state
chiedendo come faccio a vivere sono
frutto di una combinazione di tecniche
altamente innovative sono nata da una
stampante 3d e grazie alla computer
grafica riesco anche a parlare è merito
di tutto questo se catturò l'attenzione
di grandi e piccoli e raggiungo il cuore
del pubblico
ecco è questo che intendo per esperienza
grazie era prego dario
vorrei trasmettervi quello che è la
nostra passione quello che la passione
di tutto il team di officina creativa
che quotidianamente prova a trasformare
quello che sono semplici prodotti
tecnici in qualcosa di sé motivo in
qualcosa di emozionale
e quello che può diventare da un
semplice prodotto un'esperienza con
tutto il team abbiamo un'altra visione
comune
abbiamo una visione comune di lavorare
un business che non dia solo da mangiare
a noi che non ci faccio solo guadagnare
ma che lasci qualcosa sul territorio
un business etico
abbiamo un piccolo sogno quello di
trasformare la calabria in una piccola
silicon valley
grazie
[Applauso]